we're wakening up to a whole new reality
it is greg's it these guys have been
here trading since 8p and financials are
going to be absolutely front and center
folks this morning the british people
have made a very clear decision to take
a different path and as such i think the
country requires fresh leadership to
take it in this direction what we're
seeing here is the the 10-year gilt
moving below the one percent level we
haven't seen that ever ever before we
are meeting just a few days after a very
painful and regrettable decision of the
citizens of Great Britain to leave the
European Union we do respect this
decision of course but it will have to
be thought through in its consequences
if we don't come to a grown-up trade
deal between the United Kingdom and the
eurozone it will hurt the eurozone
stocks finishing the session here in
Europe the footsie has just erased its
post brexit losses check this out on our
gmm go function there will be no
negotiations of any kind until the UK
formally notifies its intentions to
withdraw instead of being afflicted by
note that I'll seize this chance and
make this our moment to stand tall in
the world that is the agenda for the
next prime minister of this country I
have concluded that person cannot be me